hey television friends we got a very
special treat right now I'm gonna be
playing a brand-new fighting game for
the Nintendo switch called arms there it
is since it's a head-to-head fighting
game I thought I should fight someone
I've always wanted to destroy publicly a
man I despise my arch enemy he's well
he's a real piece of [ __ ] Will Arnett
get in here well totally thank you guys
hey man there was no applause but there
was just the fans of taking selfies and
stuff okay there's no one here no fans
will welcome to an exact duplicate of my
apartment good to see you this is my sex
pad can you imagine that going try real
hard not to thanks for helping me out
today yeah you look like the Marlboro
Man with leukemia the game right here is
called arm arms yeah and we can attack
each other with long arms our arms are
made of ramen noodles kind of like yours
in real life ladies and gentleman if you
could feel this right now it feels like
a soft goulash that's it quite chilled
what's wrong with you you know what you
should try protein and then repetitions
of way see what they're good oh my god
yeah good it's like a ziploc bag that
had like
could have like spaghetti sauce and from
last week left on the porch yeah Wow
what's better than this flan sock you
have I say we try and play this game
yeah and you're gonna get the beatdown
of your life
whoever wins okay yeah makes the other
guy shoot a video that we put online
describing why the the winner is their
hero that would be very difficult for me
to have to do to do that that would
require I probably have to actually
become a decent actor to do that really
yeah okay well that's the deal
whoever wins the other person has to
make what's matter nothing you just
shake like you just woke up from a coma
let's play this is Adam Blaire it's
gonna step in and give us some tips Adam
one it's just as Adam or Aaron it's
Aaron um know your bill bill Arnold Bill
Arnett I'm will curious quick question
Aaron how long you worked on the show
got his name right first dry by the way
16 years 16 years no weird name
let's see you Darren okay so the game is
called arms it looks like just a normal
boxing game there's actually a lot of
strategy okay I better put this I want
to make sure I put the straps on so
there are no injuries you need to strap
on very final exam I know you'd get mad
so the first thing is you're gonna pick
a character with the little stick on the
blue there there's spring man it looks
like he's got my kind of hair you see
spring man that I could go pants bro
you're gonna hit wait are we starting
yet hold on even though they're starting
yeah
wait a minute wait a minute oh come on
come on it's time for Romanian beatdown
[Applause]
exhibition now we'll do the real one USA
right just took a two-handed okay first
of all last time it seems like last time
we had a war we act Canada won don't
remember that war was more until here
was that no no like 1812 or so I see his
trick they do look behind you Oh
[Applause]
hose that beatdown go now
Corner and I have something else to say
you began the match before I was even
ready okay the game I would hate ahead
what's that well it was out there who's
that I just said I would have hated to
have you at Normandy pay to have a guy
who couldn't speak at Normandy we're
gonna take that hill what happened oh
right he died on the beach
you're not punching you're just doing
like this what's his name is Steven
Reynolds Steven rhinos left elbow and
that's he physically getting tired well
how come you're not getting seeming to
get tired what happened there what hon
what happened to one I think you won
because of time the time you had it just
a yeah yeah because of time to take the
cowboy yeah time is on my side to quote
the Rolling Stones where if they get
much older these strolling bones look do
you want to get a medic exactly gonna
guy in here real quick you know when I
was growing up in Canada yeah I get what
was that like little something top it
was amazing you don't have a real
currency right what's that mean well the
Queen is our patron so if you want to
make fun of the Queen yeah that way you
never do that it sounds like you are
oh sorry I just killed you okay why does
that count if I was over there and not
even playing I mean the match was going
the timer why didn't you say anything
Arnold I have a I have a inkling as to
why he didn't let you know traitor
once you go over there and sit in the
corner of shame all right great posting
by the way and what some oh great not by
the way that's not real popcorn that's
asbestos because so much more than just
getting popcorn who one kid Cobra honey
win just by being great he just hit me
hit me more times it took away more like
yeah go away battle what you got to do
is you got to hit the opponent times
he's sweating no I misread me you aren't
getting tight dammit I had them just
come and spray get in tight they didn't
know it's president that's actual sweat
no sweat here identically cannot sweat I
haven't make a person he has a hole he
has three buses of people that come in
oh hey oh oh snap I think that just
happened do we get someone to blot his
forehead here do me a favor could you
start to approach me as if you were
gonna give me some of them realize I
don't need any and back away no don't
play that yes yeah just did not just
move in like oh and then be like oh no
you don't need it will is winning at the
game he has a four child if 11 games I
did I watching this other oh that's
right he brought his kids and they're
watching he's a really good guy
well the good man and I really respect
him okay I've got the results right now
and I'm about to reveal them how are you
feeling I'm nervous ma'am
cuz I don't want to have to make a video
saying nice things about you matches
Conan won four matches will one 700k you
coughed almost double burns sick burns
Conan had ten sweet sick burns we took
one off because it was a pun will 1100
Conan O'Brien here
about my hero mallanna who is so great
he's a really good-looking guy huh the
great actor and he's had a lot of
success he's got that deep voice do it
he's a legend they can hear you say that
yeah he's super smart oh dude that's so
nice of you they go my hero Will Arnett
thanks dude
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Grover get a snap Pepsi snap codes
this summer to enter for a chance to win
a Nintendo switch and other great prizes
from our friends at Pepsi and you can
see the other video games I've reviewed
at team koco.com
slash clueless gamer lazy
[Applause]
you